the war for our axis has raged on across
deserts mountains and even Tundra but
now it's time to add some roses to your
guns and crank up your welcome to the
jungle the new continent of Hassan is
now available to planetside 2 players
plus it is covered in swamps and marshes
and evokes the feel of a murky bio a
constant haze limits your visibility
overgrowth gnarled roots and hollow logs
offer cover on the ground the terrain
features so much natural cover that
guerilla tactics become the law of the
land and limit the power of brute force
the canopies of the continents forests
add depth to aerial dogfights where
pilots are fighting the terrain as much
as they're fighting enemy pilots
the facilities now posts themselves are
not entirely completed and the continent
has been labeled with an early
expedition tag still the various bases
that have been completed display how far
the level design and planetside 2 has
evolved the new base layouts feature
better interaction between the placed
objects like floors and buildings as
well as meticulously crafted terrain
along with the new continents planetside
2 now features continents locking which
completely locks the continent from
other players being able to play on it
until a new continent is locked Conant's
may be locked by taking control of at
least ninety four percent of a comments
territory or by winning alerts which are
now focused entirely on one continent at
a time during a countenance lock the
Empire responsible for the lock gets a
surgeon power on the other continents
Hassan still has the interlink
facilities to come a new base type for
planetside 2 but a familiar name to
those who play the original planetside
outfits are also now able to recruit
through an in-game recruiting system and
can display outfit pride through
purchase details once a base is captured
the game displays the decal of the
outfit whose members contributed the
most scoring points in the basis capture
that's right now- gotta take over if
you've been looking for an excuse to get
back to contributing to the war effort
on our axis the launch of the hassan
continent is what you've been waiting
for the swamps and jungles of the
perfect chance to channel your inner
Rambo as you sneak through them to
rescue allies as a lone gorilla